hey before we get into this
earth-shattering story let's introduce
the sponsor of this video astro kings
get set to blast off with the most
intense multiplayer experience the side
of the galaxy in this real time sci-fi
mobile game you control the fate of
humanity in deep space the crux have
invaded your planet and now they're
coming for your colony do you have what
it takes to survive
rebuild the world back to glory manage
your colony and collect legendary
galactic heroes to complete missions and
lead your group into victory and
conquest
it doesn't matter if you're using an ios
device android or windows you can join
with other players now to create
powerful alliances and battle in epic
mmo and pvp battles download the game by
clicking the link in the description
below or scan the qr code
get on board commander we have a galaxy
to save
and now it's time to change the face of
the planet
millions of years ago
all the continents were won
waiting to crack and spread into the
world we know today
thing is earth's ground is constantly
moving so
how about we fast forward and bring
two of them back together
south america
and africa
if these two land masses fused together
how disastrous would that be
what new animal species would it create
and why would this union be more of a
reunion
this is what if and here's what would
happen if south america and africa join
together 300 million years ago there was
just one continent on our planet pangaea
but this supercontinent was not meant to
last
that's because the rigid outermost shell
of earth's crust
the lithosphere is broken up into
several plates
these plates are floating on top of the
mantle which means that they can move
and they do
as a result of the mantle shifting
pangaea broke up in phases
from these pieces several smaller
supercontinents were formed only to also
eventually break apart
one of them was gondwana
some of which was what we now know as
africa and south america
during the time when dinosaurs still
roamed the globe this massive landmass
was covered in rainforests
but its division started when these
future regular continents started to
drift apart
when this all ended the south atlantic
ocean stood between them
but hold on since these plates continue
to move
there's a possibility that these two
continents will meet again
of course you don't have a couple
hundred million years to wait for this
to happen so let's fast track it
if you lived to see these two continents
merge
what would this epic reunion look like
now normally continents move at a speed
of one and a half centimeter per year
assuming africa and south america met
halfway in the south atlantic ocean
it would take them
230 million years to join
so let's say the mantle beneath them was
especially restless due to unprecedented
circumstances on our planet
this would violently shake the plates of
these two continents and push them
toward each other
now even if they only traveled about as
fast as us humans tend to walk a mere
speed of 1.3 meters per second well then
africa and south america would reunite
in about 30 days
yeah it would be quite the shaky journey
literally causing massive earthquakes on
both continents
and month-long earthquakes
aren't fun
but you gotta admit that's a fair price
to witness the formation of afro-america
all right it may not be the coolest of
names but it'll do for this video
this new super continent would
automatically become the largest in the
world
one and a half times bigger than asia
and the countries making the cross-ocean
move would have to deal with new
neighbors
nigeria and cameroon would now border
brazil
uruguay would be side by side with
angola while argentina would border
south africa
and a brand new mountain range would
form between the two sections of
afromerica
this would provide a natural border
between nations which might help ease
potential tensions about land
distribution
unfortunately these kind of elevations
can take many millions of years to form
so in the meantime
countries would have to resort to
diplomacy to figure out their borders
just imagine living in brazil
now sure you'd experience an influx of
cultures and a potential boom in tourism
but on the other hand
i'd box away most of your swimwear
because all of the country's coastal
regions would cease to exist
and that's going to bring an end to the
beach culture that's integral to its
lifestyle
afromerica would also be quite the
exporter of goods
south america alone produces and sells a
vast array of foods from sugar to
bananas
beef and corn
add to that fuel and raw materials
now africa is no slouch either they
export textiles and clothing as well as
all things related to petroleum
and let's not forget that it supports
the second largest mineral industry in
the world
and with renewable energy on the rise
many of these minerals like copper and
nickel
would grow in demand
but then there's the issue of animal
migration
with no mountains in their way species
unique to each continent could start to
spread into new territories
go camping in the amazon forest and you
could cross paths with an african
elephant a hippopotamus or a spotted
hyena
and open your window in nigeria and you
could spot a sloth a capybara or even a
giant anteater in your garden
of course you'd also come across unusual
plants and
insects
now if you're a nature freak this
crossover might sound exciting but it
would be nothing but bad news for
regional ecosystems
the newly arrived species would become
predators competitors and parasites of
native plants and animals
not to mention potential disease
spreaders
all of that would threaten biodiversity
it would take a long time before a new
equilibrium is found in the bordering
regions
but once things were settled some
species might interbreed and new animal
hybrids could emerge
we already have lepons ligers and
beefalos
we could see more of those but it would
take thousands of years
now on a more positive note afroamerica
might host a great cultural reunion to
go along with its geographical
reconnection
after all there is already a shared
connection between the two continents
going back as far as the early 1500s
many of the enslaved africans that were
forcefully removed from their countries
were transported to south america
and like it happened then the meeting of
these two continents would spur a
cultural exchange
oh and don't forget the languages
some brand new languages could emerge
over time like a mix of spanish and zulu
in argentina
but
let's go back to those one-month-long
earthquakes
you know if they're the only thing that
would create afro-america
well
maybe there would be
very little left to reunite
and that's barring the possibilities of
the tremors going on for
way
way longer
like i'm talking about a full year
now
that's a story
for another
what if and don't forget click on the
link below to download astro kings to
begin your space conquest